i installed a mod on all your pcs that
makes you move at 100 times the normal
speed that's way crazy
the animals are going that fast too look
at them oh look at that sheep we all
move 100 times faster and we break
blocks a hundred times faster in exactly
one hour we will fight the ender dragon
no we can do it and if in one hour we
are not in the end and then we don't
proceed to beat the ender dragon we have
to do 100 sprints on a basketball court
oh i'll throw up it's time we get hard
hard all right time begins now one hour
boys let's do it
all right so who's focusing on what
chandler you're really good at finding
diamonds you should find diamonds okay
it's pretty hard to go inside doors are
we just gonna stay 100 miles an hour the
whole time yep that's literally the
point of the challenge uh people don't
like watching us be happy i have to lay
a block to stop me when i dart forward
i'm gonna go look into this village oh
wait that iron golem oh my god oh he's
look at him
is he aggro i don't think so i'm just
gonna go into the side i don't even need
a pig stealing all the villagers crops
oh my god plants like grow instantly yo
wait wait we might have an unlimited gta
money glitch oh that's fast if i could
just slow down for i know
i literally can't stop too late i'm
moving too quick
ah stopping is the hardest part oh my
god just shift boys chandler's a genius
when did you get this smart oh hold down
crouch
hold down crouch wait i just thought of
this everybody we could just hold down
crouch thank you carl if only someone
would have thought of that sooner just
shift boys yeah
the knock back what is wrong with you
what's hitting me help help
chris wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute
where are you finding all this desert
temple he's like all you had to do was
switch to creative mode
look at that alpaca hey i'll pack in my
bags
oh my gosh dude creepers are terrifying
oh no no no no no oh gosh oh man so we
back in the mine got our big cat
swinging from high to side side side to
side shut up yo i'm going so fast on my
horse
bro
yo skeletons are in it
dude mobs are going a thousand miles an
hour i'm literally just sitting at the
top just waiting i was about to say
skeletons are inaccurate as honk and
then i just got shot oh my gosh does
everything despawn faster oh i fell in a
ravine but there's water but there's
creepers oh i'm terrified i'm terrified
i'm terrified
no i'm gonna die oh i fell into a ravine
also and there was also water
i died
ow no no you have to be kidding me
oh my gosh dude no i had full health and
a skeleton just one shot me you living
your life wrong bro just do this until
the night's over mining with iron
pickaxe is so quick
diamond yeah
oh did you guys say
diamond ahoy and guess guess who has an
obsidian source as well you don't have
to guess it's me guys we're gonna win it
this is all for everybody don't forget
oh i found where i died no but my stuff
despawned of course it's been like 10
minutes
the fish move faster these fish are
flying through the air i'm stuck
underground without wood we only have 30
minutes left dude i'm killing it getting
a full stack of iron i have diamonds and
i have obsidian oh wait i found a mine
shaft oh more diamonds question mark you
guys good with more diamonds no actually
i'm not oh cause i could stop i'm
getting tired oh oh oh i've i found an
enderman all right he's gonna give us an
ender pearl oh lava how fast does lava
travel all right i'm at 30 why why am i
here more like it
oh my god mining so fast i'm sonic
oh my god this is amazing
did you find diamonds two how many
i don't know one
two
three four five three four five we both
found five
diamonds more what the heck it's
starting to feel like i'm cheating i'm
hunting for enderman i will make myself
useful please do we need enderman and we
need uh spiders we need bows all right
so how about we delegate who wants to go
to the nether and get blaze rods i've
been doing so well with diamonds yeah me
too all right boys come back up to the
spawn let's start collecting things
chris you're looking good chris i'm
getting bullied i'm getting bullied i'm
gonna just stay up here nope nope nope i
you got a tower you got a tower right
now here's the thing boys we need ender
pearls and blaze rods i'm coming brother
oh actually open up my venue oh wait all
my armors boys come down let's have a
meeting at the nether portal get away
from me get away from me i literally
can't even hit this thing i'm just gonna
hide over here gentlemen now that we're
all armored up we still need ender
pearls and blaze rods before we can kill
the ender dragon all right
or we have to do 100 sprints all right
let's go oh wait i forgot my pickaxe i
need to pick x
how did you get over there guys look at
him i forgot we were going at a hundred
seconds i'm coming
okay what why would you do that
i need a minute well we only have 15. so
let's hurry up
because we're going so fast i thought i
went over and my heart stopped
oh no no no oh my god no wait chris look
at my hearts look at my heart i found
the fortress oh dude i found it you're
kidding me i have one rod i have one rod
so far got a rod got a rod got a run
good run run run gotta run and go to
ride get a rod run rod hey throw it up
here throw it up here how many do we
have i have five i have four blaze
[Music]
i have five blazer rods i'm giving them
to chris everybody throw them to chris
and see how much we have now holy
guacamole dude i just want some ender
pearls there yo i got a wither skeleton
skull
okay i got one i got i got an ender
pearl oh i got one too okay so i have
two ender pearls how many do you have
one one three total for me now we got
six let's go we out here we doing it
fight me like a man coward you coward
behind your trailer
oh i found they're in this ravine come
to the ravine there's so many eggs down
here hey your boy's got four eggs now
hey behind us behind us yes this ravine
is the spot yes all right boys let's
meet back up at the nether portal all
right i'm back all right let's go back
now this pikmin wants to come with us
though is that okay mom can i keep them
back to the world all right are we ready
i have ender this way guys we've been
cutting it close we have five minutes
hurry up
this way guys guys we got four minutes
we're going as fast as we can jump all
right channel throw another one it's
still going to stretch
do you know how many sprints a hundred
sprints oh it's about a hundred i hate
my friends
oh it broke it broke it broke all right
book it book it book it book yeah i hope
everybody brought everything they needed
because there's no chance we're finding
our stuff again i have an inventory full
of cobble we're good it's still this way
oh jumping is so unbearably slow oh my
god auto jump turn auto jumping just so
hard i don't want to turn auto jump on
for when we get in the end i don't want
to turn auto jump on because i'm not
stupid it helps when you're going a
thousand miles an hour i keep forgetting
there is fall damage almost time we have
three minutes and 40 seconds oh wait we
have to get to the end by then right
yeah i'm actually genuinely worried to
lose each other right now oh
yes yes we found it don't tell me it's
right over the water i'm going down
we're digging straight down i don't care
about the rules
oh found it wait what's your coordinates
i gotta make it two we only have two
minutes left negative 15 38 38 870. guys
guys guys cobweb we can break that for
string oh yeah yeah well we're gonna
have bows we literally have 70 seconds
i'm coming down
all right i'm here did anyone find the
end portal we're trying uh guys 30
seconds 30 seconds what do we do i'm
going
oh i found it did you i found it chris
yes and there's already three eyes all
right go go go do the thing good there's
three eyes already where is it i don't
have the rest chandler has three who has
the rest chandler all right go trailer
oh did you guys do it we did it yeah
there's ten seconds left you have to go
in
there's five oh wait we didn't make bows
i know that's why i was saying but i
have i have the supplies to make bows
one i didn't make it oh man i didn't
make it to the indoor portal in time so
i'm gonna take my headset off if you
guys don't manage to kill the ender
dragon we have to do 100 sprints does
anybody have arrows i have
one one singular era all right so carl
hi
do me a favor and kill that dragon so i
don't have to run
oh my god he's traveling a hundred
thousand miles an hour no he's not
please don't tell me yeah he is i love
coming in chandler's room
i've got the first beacon done he's
trying to hit me right now yeah how many
how much water
bro what's hitting me
bro using magic i'm going for it guys
i'm going for the second tower for the
second beacon
okay i killed one i killed one i just
showed a beacon i just heard a beacon i
destroyed it can i destroy it all right
three beacons down here we go here we go
here we go hey carl
you just want to put the entire team on
your shoulders
oh run
i'm gonna leave
chris you're our only hope where are you
all right i'm going he the ender
dragon's going specifically after me
right now if you don't kill the ender
dragon we all have to do 100 sprints i
can't sprint so i have to taylor
taylor
what chris died
carl died
chandler died he just ran away and i
never made it which means we have to do
100 sprints
and go
this is gamer sprints
[Music]
whose idea was this literally yours
maybe we should just win minecraft
challenges
69. we did it 31
more i finished we did 100 laps hit
subscribe